nobody likes to think about it but the
truth is every time you get behind the
wheel of a car you're risking your life
no matter how cautiously you drive you
could end up becoming a statistic one of
them more than 1 million people who died
in car related deaths globally each year
but you know you've got a life to live
and places to go so you take that risk
again and again it turns out however one
automaker is working on a new kind of
car one that could help reduce that risk
to zero I've come to Munich to visit BMW
here at its research and innovation
center the company is developing sensor
technology that can do something very
simple but also very important prevent a
car from crashing into anything what
happens when this car starts to close in
on a stationary object it waits for you
until you get too close until you have a
certain threshold and then it starts
breaking for you and prevents the
collision all right so I get behind the
wheel yes please
okay so I should just start driving
toward that yeah
okay I'm gonna for it hmm it just stops
uh-huh it just stops I gotta do that yet
the way the car works is it has really
really precise laser scanners that
perceive where the obstacles are and how
big they are
the system builds up a map and then
estimates its movement inside these
obstacles and as soon as we get too
close
it breaks for you in a comfortable way
if it can it slams on the brake if the
situation gets really critical and
therefore prevents collisions so before
we test the car in the real world we
simulate whether the algorithms work the
way they were intended to and as you can
see the car slowed automatically down in
the simulation and therefore avoided the
collision really really well the
ultimate goal of course is to prevent
any collisions at all how far we can get
with that depends on how many people
will actually use this kind of
technology when we have 100% of the cars
equipped with collision avoidance
there's a good chance that we can almost
prevent any kind of accident so as you
can see here we set up an obstacle
course right because we've seen already
how the car performs when it's
approaching something from the front but
the system is actually monitoring the
sides of the car the back of the car
every which way around it everywhere
yeah okay so at first I'll drive like
like I know what I'm doing
I'm this way I were to kind of be a
little bit too close and this would
actually hit your door right and it
could really mess up my paint job this
system is still just a prototype and it
doesn't always work perfectly but it is
the beginning of something as computers
and sensors and cars become smarter and
more precise they end up doing more of
the driving while people do less and
less some years from now that could mean
our cars drive themselves but in the
near term it's going to mean safety
systems that can make up for all those
human flaws that get us in trouble on
the road in the first place we're
talking about systems that never
hesitate never get distracted and see in
all directions the crash proof car isn't
quite here yet
but it's coming